cbs news confirms this morning that cia
director william burns went to
afghanistan where he met yesterday with
the taliban's leader u.s troops
controlling the city's airport expect to
learn today if a deadline to leave
afghanistan next week will be extended
european allies are pushing president
biden to stay longer but the taliban
have said they will not accept that a
white house official says about 21
600 people were flown out of afghanistan
in just the past 24 hours that's an
increase thousands of westerners and
many more afghans are still waiting to
get out however our roxanna siberia is
in qatar that's the destination for many
thousands of evacuees and we see her
there
with one week to go before the august
31st deadline evacuations from kabul's
airport are picking up pace the pentagon
says 37 u.s military flights airlifted
out more than 21 thousand people in 24
hours the highest one-day figure so far
it also confirmed that u.s troops made a
second rescue off airport grounds
yesterday extracting several stranded
americans but it's unclear how many
american citizens and at risk afghans
remain and if the u.s will need more
time to get them out pentagon spokesman
john kirby i am not going to speculate
about
post august 31st we are head down
focused on keeping these numbers up as
best we can getting as many people out
as we can by the end of the month the us
says for now the taliban are cooperating
with american troops at the airport
though taliban spokesman suhail shaheen
told us the august 31st deadline is a
red line it is a
violation
violation of the commitment
that
president biden
has made
in the capital signs of everyday life
are returning though now taliban flags
are for sale and banks and schools are
still closed
thousands who have made it out past
these crowds at kabul's airport are
flowing into u.s bases in places like
germany and washington's dulles airport
where yesterday these refugees landed
carrying their kids and hopes for a
brighter future
the pentagon says evacuees who travel to
the u.s will be temporarily housed at
four military bases across the country
with facilities that could eventually
hold up to 25 000 people for cbs this
morning roxanna suberi doha